I'm gonna start off with this this
position from which is from a study
which means someone made made up this
position someone named Siletz key made
sup and funny that this has the same
theme as what we were just doing in in
the beginner lesson the smothered
checkmate buts if we look at this
position there no pawns left it's only
knights and bishops and queens so in
general it would be a draw but here
White has a momentary advantage and
white actually has more active pieces
right as we said we night so we compare
the Knights which Knight is more active
the white one is right and if we compare
the Queen's the White Queen is more
active too right
well I don't know I mean well it's
closer to the black King I guess you
know it's also white smooth which is a
big difference but in general this
material balance would just be a draw
even if White's more active in my it's
generally just gonna be a draw but here
white has a chance to do something so
also with especially the knight this is
dangerous piece for black because Knight
up by the King and Queen that's gives a
start makes us start to think there
might be a fork of some sort coming up
and different so this but you get this
position on the board and in tournament
game you got to start looking canned and
try to use your chance while it exists
and white has a real cool way to win so
anyone see a good move though the other
tech right so Bishop a6 now work in the
King go or what can black two
yeah it has to go to b8 because if black
King goes here again got the same thing
right what happens here before right 96
and Bishop here in this case yeah I
wouldn't bother to look at but even if I
did it would it becomes pretty clear
that either way the King goes then it's
a fork 97 or 96 so King bees the only
move
now what get two good checks by the
Queen and this one would be tricky
because Queen e5 looks natural but if we
figure out the main idea we're gonna
realize that we need our queen we need
to avoid any checks by black okay
Queenie five centralizing the Queen
looks normal but that's not the right
move okay because after here our idea
which I'm not going to show you yet done
doesn't work because black has because
black has checks on the GFL okay so so
actually Queen g3 is right okay but I
can't really show you why would I come
back to it so what can black do now has
to go to the corner and now does any
this is the hard part does anyone see an
idea here for white
this is gonna involve in a moment
a quiet move that's that's the one point
where a relatively quiet move in other
words and not a check but that's the
point where you have to be you know
looking for yeah 96 okay that looks that
looks yeah it's it's not trick me that
black would probably black was should
yeah it is that's the that some of our
would look at and it's the first move I
would look at in this position but black
but I don't think there's a checkmate I
mean there's no checkmate here let's see
what block can do yeah and I think this
is this is the way to to defend I think
because you got to keep your Queen no
because white is gonna have discovered
checks so you have to keep the Queen far
away but here if white white doesn't
have it you know you got to check right
but is there a good follow up yeah this
move and then checkmate so that's it
that's a nice one ok 96 let's see what
because because it shouldn't win there
shouldn't be two solutions here how
about instead
you know anything black might need to do
I think black needs to do this okay now
now the check doesn't doesn't do
anything because discovered check will
just be met by taking the Queen right so
I didn't want to do that first but
because of because of this which looks
fatal but black can black can block it
looks like remember blacks got his own
big attack over here now Queen and
Bishop working together and takes right
king there is there any follow-up now
lights up a piece but checkmate is
threatened White's pieces aren't
coordinating very well so I don't see
any I don't see any particularly good
follow-up here for white I don't know
but but anyway so so that's that's 96 as
the first move moves 96 is the first
move I would look at but it does look
dangerous but I guess Queen of three is
the defense and maybe it's the only
defense because if the Queen moves
somewhere else
Knight c7 an IC 7 followed by 95 96 but
Queen f3 huh
so what else could we do here in this
position
which a way to
yeah our Queens well-placed for now huh
there's only one other forcing move
right I mean that's anywhere near
reasonable so Bishop to b7 check right
it's does two things it blocks the king
has to take it it also loses control for
black over this now comes Knight there
okay black has to up a piece now but
White has two big threats
one is obviously to take the Queen right
what's the other one yeah the Queen
leaves then Queen of EA and also Knight
to be six okay
can black save the queen and defend b6
oh there's a way
yeah I've also noticed they have no
counter-attacks - that's important if
the Queen was on e5 black would have a
check on g8 which would save them so
that's why Queens you threw yours better
so earlier on in the game but here
there's no checks yeah the night covers
c5 you know otherwise that would be you
know there's only one way to save the
Queen and guard b6 it doesn't lose the
Queen like Queen to d6
I mean the d8 there's nothing else
really otherwise black minimum losses
the Queen and then it's easy now can you
see how white wins this queen is
overworked it's guarding b6 + b8 if the
Queen was not there Queen to be eight
would be checkmate right so it has to
guard those both of those I mean you
have peace it's over works you've got to
call it up for duty on one thing that is
and then it has to leave the post
okay so Queen to b8 though right is that
so okay good that one now the Queen has
to take yeah and now that does two
things not defending b6 and it's
blocking b8 so now of course checkmate
so all that just to end up with this
little tiny position over here in the
corner of a checkmate
it's all forced yeah is down the queen
and a bishop it's all forced from the
beginning completely forced I mean I
deleted the beginning of this but you
know from from this position check check
check
Knight there no other way to defend cuz
block could give up the Queen somehow
but it's gonna be it's gonna be then I'm
quickly winning for weight and okay
let's see the next one what we have here
okay just a second
okay this one this is a real crazy
position okay white this time White's up
two nights but he's got a problem right
it's a problem like has this past pawn
on g3 okay and can you stop it
the thing is Knights can sometimes do
incredible things with catching pawns
they can really amaze you they're on one
side of the board and through some sort
of weird tactics with forks and checks
and things like that they can catch the
pawn it here amazingly blacks whites
able not to catch the pawn but they can
they can save the game and draw yeah
okay we've got to consider that - okay
h6 is that actually the right move okay
black has to take that pawn because if
they promote they both promote I mean
blacks definitely not going to win if
both sides promote so black has to take
the pawn and of course if the King tries
to do something tricky like this now the
knight can come up with check so that
doesn't it just doesn't help you know so
so sort of takes the pawn and now what
well there's different places we could
get the night - we can try all different
kinds of stuff here yeah I mean we can
try to control the pond there's another
idea that's actually how wait so what do
you think
which Knight to d6 this one are the CA
Wow this one yeah what's this is
actually the solution I'll show you it's
hard to find it you have to you have to
go through I have to wade through a
whole bunch of different possibilities
but Knight to d6 okay so threatening
Knight f5 right if the King goes to g5
what is way 294 right that's easy
they take the pawn what if the King goes
to g6 check out the other night and that
doesn't help okay
so black pushes the pawn of course now
what okay which way okay
now black has to decide where to go does
what happens if the King goes there yeah
that's easy right
yeah takes upon dense the draw what
about this one
what is what is way to then
well then black Queens yeah
94 good getting ready to fork on f3 and
also getting ready to go 92 so queen
Knight f3 and otherwise King G 492 and
the key is once you all once you've got
the knight in controlling the square in
front of the pawn if it's not the rook
pawn it can't be chased away even if it
is the rook pawn if it's if it's the one
before the the last one it can't be
chased away you and well if it's not the
rook pawn like if it's a jeep on to a
beep on even if it doesn't matter as
long as it controls so honest it can get
in contact with the part of the square
in front of the pond you can't be chased
away no matter what you do so for
instance here here here here you know
wherever wherever it goes it's not going
to be able to you know here then can
come back and so let's see what else
could you know you can yeah so so in
some cases there could be a situation
where the king could attack the knight
but and usually it it'll be able to move
away where if the Queen the pawn it will
fork
okay so King to g5 didn't work king to
g6 didn't work what about King to h5
does that work I was way to now check
and now you two right okay
so black only has one one move it's the
obvious move because you want to stay
away from all these things you know the
forks and stuff so King age 7 yeah age 7
I mean that's the only other teen age 7
can wait stopped upon no but now white
goes here okay
so black has to make a queen and now the
chemo King to be four there's a draw
because if you look at the black King
that can come here it can't come here
here here
you can go back and forth but so the
King can't and get out of it this cage
and the Knights protect each other okay
so the King is completely stuck in a
cage the Knights protecting each other
they can't be taken or there's only one
way black could win what's that
there's one plan that black could have
like in this position let's say if white
played the wrong move yeah yeah put
white and zoogs on the only way is to
force the King into the corner so it
would be basically like a stalemate if
there were no knights there and that
would force one of the knights to move
so if white made a mistake in went King
b3 then he's gonna get forced into the
corner eventually it's gonna be like
let's say King b3 could try that with
him here and eventually there or if if
King went here then then this this you
know minimum like that and then the
knight has to move and when the knight
moves the other one's gonna get forked
and lost like remove this you know check
and take whatever there's lots of
different ways so so you can't allow the
King to be stalemated but after King
before
there's no way to stalemate the white
king as long as why it's careful there's
no way because King can stay over by
these Knights and there will be no way
to stalemate it because the Knights are
gonna interfere with the black Queens
movement well yeah I mean good start
like this but I think you have to you
have to think a little bit of course to
make sure but up here I don't think this
can
because can't go here here here it goes
up here yeah so you can't as long as the
king is up on this side I don't see any
way you can
you can wait but then King comes back
and if you move the Queen from the C
file it gets over there somewhere you
know so as long as you avoid that stale
stale mate situation which can only
really happen down here or over here I
mean in the corner down here or maybe
down here even down here it's not gonna
work because the night covers those
squares so it really can only happen
down there so that's why whites whites
final move King before is the key move
and then you offer a draw and your
opponent says I thought they were gonna
Queen that I was gonna clean that pawn
and win but these two nights you know
yeah yeah I'm starting positions for
straw I'm gonna we have a main game that
I chose Larsson versus Spassky this was
a very it's a pretty fast it's
instructive game okay this was from the
match from 1970 when Boris Spassky was
not a match but a sort of a match
tournament from 1970 when Boris Spassky
was a was a world champion at the time
he had the black pieces here this was
USSR versus the rest of the world they
had this I think semiannual or something
like two annual match I don't know for a
while where the top players from the
USSR played against the top players from
the rest of the world and they've had
various similar things in recent years
where a certain country would play again
just but basically it's a reason to play
chess but okay no no this took place in
Belgrade yeah this took place in
Belgrade
so Larson was white here and he chose
well I mean he chose Larson's opening
that's what it's called b3 so why is he
and chattering the bishop Larson been
Larson was a Danish player and he was a
very original type of player and he he
liked to use what
called hyper-modern ideas now was then -
originating from the same nimzowitsch in
the earlier part of the 20th century the
idea that white doesn't or either side
doesn't have to put pawns in the center
to try to control the center with pawns
but they could use their pieces from the
distance so here most common ways to
start games are efore of course and d4
or at least some move like Knight f3
fall soon after by d4 maybe but b3
doesn't put up on in the center it
allows black to put pawns in the center
but the idea is that white controls the
center from the distance the bishops can
be fianchettoed here shooting through
the center but still it's kind of an
obscure opening i actually chose to play
this in my last open my last tournament
even though i usually play e4 just for
fun like in an earlier round
Oh b3 okay Spassky Spassky was a very
classical player and he responded with E
5 putting this pawn in center and you
know do you like so he liked to play
classical style you know very gain space
active pieces you know and then real
clear and classical played Larson was a
little bit more weird player you know
okay so Bishop b2 okay attacking the
pawn knight c6 guarding it now c-4 he
chose which is another already even in a
somewhat less common opening he's
choosing a less common variation of that
it's more common to play III with the
idea that white can add pressure to the
pawn on e5 by this at some point so for
instance if d5 bishop there and now this
pawns under attack or if Knight f6 also
white this is perhaps the most common
variation of this opening is this now
threatening to take the knight and then
take the pawn and this is what a lot of
people play nowadays it's strange
looking but the idea is like it's castle
druid and then the bishop moves what he
controls e-file or he might play you for
and there should be five at some later
point but that's that's a
but that's that's um one of the lines
but arson shows this controlling d5 this
pawn but it's sort of he might as well
have played c4 I move one then and now
these these moves well King anyway
Knight of six spots key played okay he's
playing this classical style Knights
toward the center nothing tricky you
know just fight for the center with the
Knights and the most active spots and so
on Knight of three this is another a
little bit unusual move mostly because
it allows black to push the pawn so he's
provoking but he's hoping that black
pawn advances it's gonna leave some weak
squares it's gonna open up this diagonal
for the bishop and maybe the pawn itself
will be a little bit weak but at the
same time wait us to move the knight
again in black key in space
Spassky wasn't afraid and he just
advanced the pawn okay now Knight to d4
so Knight move Bishop c5 he's getting
white to take this knight on c6 he's
attacking the knight he's bringing out
the piece two active spot okay so Larson
took on c6 and now it looks normal to
recapture toward the center this is what
you learn a lot capture toward the
center but Spassky and and and this
position is also typical where the
colors reversed in a line of the
Sicilian which is known as the names of
each variation actually because it's
named after the similar ideas Larson
used a lot of Aaron names if it just
ideas and it's typical to take with a D
pawn why do you think you would take
with a deep honor other than the B long
does it take toward the center is a
typical is the usual advice right well
what's the advantage of taking with a
deep line
right you add some pressure in the
center you open up the Queen and the
bishop right away first of all so whites
deep on is a little bit backward it's a
little hard to wait to advance the deep
on the white please III is really gonna
be backward which is what's gonna end up
happening because yeah you takes on the
other hand black might push the pawn
here but it still doesn't achieve much
white will probably play III and that's
the castles Bishop e2 d5 it leaves these
really kind of seriously weak these
pawns in the future
and this deep on doesn't provide any
additional pressure really on the center
for way to have to worry about so that's
not the most that's not really what I
want what black wants to do so do you
take c6 now III so he he needs to get
his pieces into the game and he needs to
block black's pawn at some point it also
has to watch out for such ideas like
Knight to g4 in some point Queen age for
black has a lot of space from the King
sight so white has to be careful so for
instance Oh could play g3 but then then
Bishop to f5 and if he develops the
bishop that way black could get a real
strong attack bite by using this this
pawn to to advance and you know to
advance here and maybe take to take this
when white castles and open up the H
file okay so so he played III not create
not putting the bishop on g2 okay Bishop
to f5 so Spassky develops again every
move developing move fighting for the
center Larson is looking for some much
more much more difficult to explain
ideas that this pawn maybe will become
under attack or the bishop will be
strong and this that black will not be
able to make any progress and whites
will have some sort of plan
so anyway Queen to see to be played
Queen to e7 so black protects this pawn
in advance Bishop e2 and black Castle
queenside
so putting pressure
on the D file and here this was a little
bit too risky it turned out this is a
good positional move in general and this
is a typical move that why it tries to
do what happened if like okay you guys
see that black can take our path on
right that's crucial thing also if there
was no such thing as on passant then
this position would be would be a big
difference for instance here my white
might play this move you know but it's
not good here because on passant okay so
i'm poisson is really important in chess
it's not just to just not just to
whatever you know curiosity or something
ever changed trust completely if they
didn't have that rule those hey Bishop
b2 castles f4 again black can't take on
passant because the bishop on f5 would
be under attack green takes f5 so white
manages to gain some space and take
control of e5 and if y could get away
with this you probably be pretty happy I
mean you could play Knight c3 Castle
queenside he aims for maybe g4 and this
Bishop would be very strong and he could
sort of undermine the pawn on e4 this
weakness here can be guarded as long as
why he gets the Kings of Queen side it's
gonna be a quiet okay
probably but Spassky realized that
white's is asking a little too much of
the position to advance his pawn and the
variations just work out from black here
Boris Spassky trusted in his classical
developments of bringing the pieces to
active spots and not worrying too much
of you know he now he saw that it's time
he needs to start an attack because
quiet play it will be okay for white and
maybe even good for white so he played
Knight to g4 the idea is first of all to
open up the Queen and also to put
pressure on e3 so one thing that that
might happen is why it's not careful
black might take this pawn so one thing
is let's say ye takes that it says okay
I want to I'm gonna call your bluff and
take the pawn on g7
okay black attacks it goes back now
comes this and that's a very typical
destroying sacrifice and here you don't
really need to look at a whole lot of
variations to realize that this is very
dangerous for white because you can just
see that all blacks pieces are out and
whites are not really yeah yeah takes
tax the Queen Queen moves check King has
no squares as to play g3 I should close
this yeah and what do you think black
does now if you weren't looking ahead on
the notation well night to G to King
moves here maybe maybe the thing is now
if here then I suppose white can survive
by taking it because blacks own Queen is
under attack just survive it survive you
know there's enough because if King
takes well probably there's some sort of
mate like this and then made the King
comes up then looks looks very scary and
Bishop hangs but no I think that after
this Queen can take any case after this
also there's King f12 now black has
something better
yeah yeah rook takes a g3 this is
crushing because of what he takes was
black turnout yeah yeah it takes the
pawn not the road check me yeah and then
and if the if way doesn't take of course
black is threatening every kind of
discovered check double check and you
know everything like that so so that's
one example of how that sacrifice could
happen I would say blacks already
threatening Bishop takes c3 and if white
castles you'd like to do that but now
comes here threatening checkmate on h2
and the white white better take the
knight but black stands very well here
because White's been forced to give up
the very important bishop and now this
pawn is permanently back where black
will have rook there you'll have H 5 H 4
H 3 is another plan and it's not
possible to challenge this pawn now
without the bishop the light squares are
is very strong for black this this plan
of pushing the H pawn is a big thing
this is really hard for white to deal
with it even the route could come up to
g6 but with this without White's light
squared Bishop is trouble the white
plays h3 and then what do you think
black might do here
hmm
also my eggs
well I mean that's one thing to look at
to take here but Sarah is there a
follow-up here you can take the pawn the
white gives back the exchange and then
black kind of runs out of attackers I
think I suppose not
not King here because the bishop takes
h3 but King here and I'm not sure what's
going on here I I don't know maybe maybe
blacks winning also I don't know just
probably even better and they takes
Knight takes c3
can you two it's probably the only move
I guess I mean maybe that's maybe that's
good but I suppose even better is to
remove the defender like that to destroy
the pawn chain from the base if the
Queen takes then black takes on a 3-inch
eye and wins the Queen for ik right
takes there okay that's winning Knight
takes then here and this is just
devastating better even better than
taking with the bishop sometimes you
have a situation where you can take a
piece with check where you take a pawn
with check or something like that
they have to move their king or you can
take a piece and set up a discover check
but this is much much stronger because
now the Queen's under attack white
doesn't have time to even get out of the
discovered check because we'll lose the
Queen
so Queen has to run away let's say to
see one really there's no difference and
now what do you think is the best way to
finish off the attack
lots of discovered checks and stuff like
that but there's one that really
finishes well maybe there's more than
one way and I don't know there is
definitely more than one win there's one
that forces checkmate in a couple moves
Knight to g4 then King each one
yeah yeah that's one win okay you could
just take the rook and they can't take
with the king because queen f2 and so
the king would have to go but then black
sub-material quickly quickly checkmating
- I don't know
Bishop h3 or something probably quickly
leads to check me but ya know Knight f1
there's no check that I can see
immediately but any KCI blacks winning
of course but there's there's a force
checkmate in a couple moves and that's
Knight XG - let's check okay and if King
takes and checkmate in otherwise walking
doesn't just delays it for a couple
moves so that's that's that's how with
White Castle so this in a g4 the idea is
you know open up the Queen and also puts
pressure around here if white takes the
knight I didn't write it down but if he
does take tonight again he's giving up
that crucial Bishop check probably I
probably go and take it with the Queen
forces this weakness or forces the King
to move or something like that that's
terrible for a wait so g3 is wet Larsen
played he's probably still had some
trust in his position he may have been a
little nervous but it's I think he had
some trust in his position because again
as long as white gets castled he will
he'll be okay and he's probably in
Larson was a very provocative player he
he likes to allow a lot of attacks or
some sort of subtle positional purposes
you know but now spa ski continue with
this okay it's clear what he intends all
right what's blacks plan
he wants to rip the file open with h4
right White has to do something about
that because that's devastating if wait
if white plays there he's not going to
get away in time because there's no
castles made of two wins the exchange
and otherwise black takes on g3 and it's
over so he's okay I chase tonight now
this is the key moment what what is
boskie played because if you just
retreat the night in Larson's play as
triumph white goes Knight c3 castles
Queen side and that's it waits well
probably better yeah this has all the
long-term strategic ideas going for
white and black has no plan then
it's nine ideas
yeah so the question is you want to sack
it on e3 or do you want to do second in
a different way if you sack the night on
III I don't think that this is really
that clear because how are you gonna get
to the white king definitely it's a
dangerous attack but it's not it doesn't
look so so so terrible maybe I mean okay
it's scary of course I agree that it's
not easy to defend but maybe Y can just
continue like that and when black set
checks somewhere to give up the Queen
rook t2 just maybe you can sacrifice the
Queen and this is more than enough
material for the Queen rook and two
minor pieces and a king would be safe
the blacks running out of pieces I
suppose I know that's one thought just
but it doesn't look so clear there's
other moves besides Knight c3 as well
Bishop c1 for instance like has like has
this move could go here mmm surviving at
least I don't know maybe there's other
defenses but it's a it's not it's not as
good as what would Larsson played he
sacrificed the knight what he did it in
an you know really but much better way
he did this he said okay white if the
knight retreats then h4 loses teeth
completely because whenever whenever
whenever h4 is played white responds
with d4 it's is exactly what white wants
because that's you know so but when the
Knights still there black can afford to
play h4 and the King side is gonna get
broken open and in fact large Spassky
realized that rather than sacrificing on
e3 he wants these pawns to stay there
because this sort of forms a wall in
between the board and that's what makes
the sacrifice work was that white can't
bring his pieces over the mobility is
real important in this type of thing is
not that black does everything with a
forcing move here there's some points
where he makes a move which is not it
packer capture and it's just that white
doesn't have the time to bring the
pieces over so white pretty much has to
take the night because otherwise black
is gonna take on g3 anyway and of course
taking here this is terrible
you know the night of two and so on or
93 was king D one F one Queen f2 so so
he has to take the night he could take
with a bishop or with the pawn if he
takes her the bishop it's it's more or
less the same the file opens up right
and I don't want to show the solution
here yet because that's gonna show
what's gonna happen in the game but so
that's but anyway so he took with a pawn
okay now of course
Spassky does this also sacrificing this
Bishop but that's not a real sacrifice
because now black has two ideas the H
files open up and this pawn is extremely
dangerous and furthermore there's a
Queen's check here coming later on and
upon advances so that was a really
brilliant idea but it's and I think that
Larsson saw this and I'm sure he saw it
but what he didn't see it was another
couple moves even more brilliant idea
that everyone had missed and which spa
ski saw from up front okay so he he had
to play rook g1 he has to keep the rook
back there to defend his back rank if he
if he trades rooks now rook each one is
coming and there's no way out for
instance King F 1 he just comes in like
that and the pieces started coming in
around the white king and if you know if
he just tries to keep developing then
then this is crushing the pawns about to
become a second Queen white castles rook
takes and then next next comes a queen
and have ninety two and then this is
enough and it's just too much you know
like it's not even down anything here
so so you can't he can't afford to trade
rooks
and if he could castle if he had one
more development tempo with Knight c3
then the whole thing would be different
he would Castle queenside get his King
away and no more attack for black the
pawns not going anywhere with two rooks
guard in the back rank but White's just
one temple behind so he had to go rook
to you one now is we're probably Larsson
saw this saw saw a you know the idea of
age for sacrificing the night but he
didn't see the amazing move that Spassky
played next so what is Foskey gonna do
now she would like to advance the pawn
but the rook takes and then if check the
King runs away or well actually if he
advances the pawn
he advances the pond and I suppose white
can how about if a bit movie goat
well I suppose white can give back
material somehow Queen Queen they're
cleaning f2 now this is this is losing
have to after g2 maybe here's what we
can do can take check bishop f1 and if
Queen h4 rook F 2 is their way through
now rook h2 maybe this and then this I
don't know it does look dangerous but it
looks like white is surviving and here
what I remember whites up a lot of
material
I don't know so the g2 doesn't work
what's that no it's White's move after
g2 yeah I mean that's a threat rook each
one but Natan this is also maybe maybe
I'm not sure if this this might work to
the idea you come here and then Knight
c3 and black can't get the Queen in is
the point g5 so I'm not sure exactly
what any case this Larsen had check this
stuff in it and it didn't appear to work
however he didn't see it was the
pasquese next move was he did this move
he just moved his rook there anyway so
that g2 will come with with with with
tempo okay so White has to take those
the rook right as if if King f1 the
Queen comes in and now it's for instance
black threatens to take the rook and
then Queen h2 Queen f2 that's there's no
way to stop that so if white goes Ric f1
then comes G 2 so y definitely has to
take the rook right now g2 black
threatens to just take these bikes now
down a piece and a rook but he's
threatening to take the rook back and
gain everything back and a second Queen
so here's Fosse or Larsson played a
desperate move rook f1 the reason as he
saw differ up G one natural move right
then comes Queen h4 and Queen h1 and
that the extra tempo that black used to
give by giving away the rook was was
everything and there's no defense for
white here blacks about to take the rook
and if it takes then there's no there's
the back rank mate there's no escape and
if white tries to make to runway with a
king now there's gonna be a second Queen
and patent takes and here for instance
with if they're deflecting the Queen if
Queen takes then comes Queen d3 followed
by that so so that that's one way the
game could end if white if white right
so Larsson you know he saw these lines
and he's okay he tries to at least to
give back the rook and just get rid of
that pawn and remember he's up a rook in
a minor piece so if he could get back
the rook and not lose anything else he
would still be winning but now comes
check and now he takes the now he takes
the rook and then Larsson resigned
because he saw that that after after
Bishop takes the only move then comes
here and if Bishop e2 then then Queen to
h1 is mate okay you can't block right
and if King does c1 then what yeah
Queen e1 and that's made next to Queen
d1 Queen takes so this was this rook h1
was the key